everything that you want is on the other
side of hard but you got to fall in love
with the work
he is the point God you got old Chris
Paul down at the end the Great point
guards in the history of the game an
Olympian president of the NBA Players
Association 12-time All-Star if you
didn't know now you know sport has
taught me everything in life it's taught
me about sacrifice hard work it's taught
me about pain what was it about your
grandfather that made him such an
indelible figure in your life the day
before Jones was killed he was here
watching his grandson sign with Wake
Forest is that Wake Forest hat that
Chris is wearing in that shot
Chris sees on a plan to honor his
grandfather in his next game scoring one
point for every year of his
grandfather's life
it just made me feel different
Man this ain't supposed to be this kind
of podcast